[موسيقى]
القصر الملكي في ماليزيا هو بيت السياسه
والسلطان تحول في هذه الاونه ما بعد
الانتخابات الى مركز النفوذ للحسم عندما
يغيب التوافق
الله خمسه ايام من الجدل كلف الملك بعدها
رئيس اكبر كتله في البرلمان بتشكيل حكومه
وحده وطنيه
ابريق تي سي
الديمقراطيه بالطبع قياده الكتل التي تكسب
الانتخابات هي التي تفرز رئيس الوزراء لكن
الخاسره لا يخسرون نهائيا والفائز لا يفوز
بكل شيء وهذه هي الديمقراطيه التي ارادها
جلاله الملك
[تصفيق]
تعهد انور ابراهيم بالحفاظ على المبادئ
التي قامت عليها ماليزيا لاسيما الحفاظ
على الاسلام دين الدوله والنظام الملكي
رمزي سيادتها
ورفض تقديم تنازلات بشان المبادئ التي قام
عليها برنامجه الانتخابي بينما يستعد
لتشكيل ائتلافه الحكومي
وسرعان ما تلقى انور ابراهيم دعما من دول
اسلاميه مثل تركيا واندونيسيا
اعتقد انه لا يوجد تجارب في البرامج
الانتخابيه لمختلف الكتل الحزبيه وقد
تضمنت التصريحات جيدا لكن التحدي يكمن في
تنفيذ هذه التعاهدات والاجندات فساد جائعه
ضخمه يجب اتخاذ اجراءات لمواجهتها بفعاليه
شكك رئيس التحالف العقد الوطني محي الدين
ياسين في شرعيه حكومه انور ابراهيم واصر
انه مازال يملك الاغلبيه
وذلك على الرغم من اعلان التحالف الجبهه
الوطنيه انضمامه الى حكومه وحده وطنيه
والذي تحول مع احزاب اخرى الى مرجح في
التوازنات السياسيه الجديده اعتبركه
ناشونال لقد طلب من قاده تحالف العقد
الوطني المشاركه في الحكومه لكنهم رفضوا
ثم شكوا وترددوا وفي الحقيقه نحن لسنا
مضطرين اليهم
تحسبا لاعمال عنف جراء حملات تحريض
وكراهيه رصدتها الشرطه الماليزيه في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعيه اعلنت حاله التاهب
ونشرت وحدات من عناصرها في المناطق
الحساسه
[تصفيق]
اما الاحزاب التي احتفت بالفوز في
الانتخابات
فطلبت من انصارها الامتناع عن الاحتفال في
الاماكن العامه
حكومه وحده وطنيه ستقود البلاد في المرحله
المقبله بعد فشل اي من الكتل السياسيه في
الحصول على الاغلبيه وما تلى ذلك من حاله
عدم يقين شهدتها ماليزيا منذ الاعلان عن
نتائج الانتخابات
لكنها اعادت انور ابراهيم الى صداره
المشهد السياسي بعد عقود من الانتظار
سامر علاوي الجزيره والالمبور